[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es eine leckere tat und die
backe ich nicht alleine sondern mit
ich habe hier einen hut gebracht
schleife bei uns heißt schlug aber ich
kenne abschluss ich glaube die alex
acker aufschlug
goldig und wir machen heute tat in der
oster tat und dies auch wirklich super
einfach wir machen einen hellen teig für
unten rein und andere braune füllung und
schöne ostereier noch in die mitte super
einfach vor allem kann man super
vorbereiten auch am tag vorher schon die
tat die hinteren kühlschrank drei vier
fünf tage aber ich glaube so lag mit die
heldt nicht wir zeigen euch mal die
zutaten wird in moerdijk für den
mürbeteig verwenden wir 55 gramm zucker
110 gramm kalte butter 165 gramm mehl
eine prise salz und etwas wenn elektra
und das ist übrigens per 123 überzeugt
ich habe nämlich einen teil sogar
zweiteiler butter drei teile mähen und
dann nehme ich immer gerne auf dem
eigelb dazu weil es besser bindet
bisschen ball exakt unser kann man sich
gut merken hier machst du also das kann
man auch in der küchenmaschine machen
mit dem knethaken oder mit dem mixer
mach ich es meistens ganz einfach viel
schneller geht für rühr oder verkneten
meist zuerst butter und zucker also kam
ich noch nicht dass das mittel sich löst
kann sie auch direkt zu einem teig zu
ackern das heißt ich sage ja für was
nimmt man den sonst so hat es
tatsächlich hier
da nehme ich immer normales weizenmehl
also nicht dass freien rieselnde mail
weil es einfach sein zu fallen wird kann
ich im sand schon rein ja das eigelb
alles ist genau geschaut die tat schon
probiert lecker lecker
ich habe sie ihnen wirklich schon mal
zubereitet bei mir immer wichtig ist
immer wichtig dass er nicht so lange
geknetet wird damit er schön kalt bleibt
und die butter die vermischt sich jetzt
schon mit dem mehl einfach durch
bisschen hand wärme
aber wie gesagt nicht zu lange kneten
einfach nur kurz bis auch schön zusammen
kommt meistens mit dem mixer aber ich
könnte so macht auch spaß
ich liebe es mit den tag genau passiert
er kommt ganz schnell zusammen ja das
ist eigentlich gleich fertig und auf
meinem blog da habt ihr die umrechnung
tabelle
und dann könnt ihr zum beispiel auch die
tat größer machen oder kleine machen ich
mache jetzt immer oder wir machen 16 25
cm tat aber man kann sich ja auch größer
oder kleiner erscheinen lassen
ob sala und beim umrechnen mache ich
einfach immer so ich rechne
den teig um und dann gebe ich aber
trotzdem meist nur ein eigelb rein also
egal ob ein wunder kleiner und ja das
passt jetzt noch gestört abdecken und
dann für eine stunde kühl stellen und
wir können derzeit schon mal die führung
für die promi führung verwenden wir 100
gramm butter 200 gramm dunkle schokolade
herren schokolade 120 gramm zucker 3 1
200 gramm sahne 30 km kakaopulver dass
es umgesetzt eine prise salz und etwas
tonkabohne für die befüllung nehmen wir
jetzt erstmal die partie kommt in den
topf und wird geschmolzen einfach bei
mittlerer stufe dann gehen wir da gleich
nämlich die schokolade dazu bittet die
höhe
und ich hol schon mal eine rutsche eine
rührschüssel
[Musik]
gibt die schokolade übrigens immer erst
danach bezahlt damit sie einfach nicht
verbrennen also jetzt erst mal die
butter schmelzen und die hitze die
reicht dann meist auch schon aus für die
schokolade kalorien und dann fühlt
nämlich auch die butter gleich für
darüber kann die wohnung fertig statt
das ist ganz wichtig nicht zu heiß
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt einfach die hitze auf
stufe 2 also ganz ganz ganz gering
jetzt die schokolade dazu und so lange
rühren bis die geschmolzen ist fesche
wie es riecht
[Musik]
während die er es noch die schoko
berührt kann ich hier schon mal die eier
verrühren
die eier in eine rührschüssel sogar dazu
auf vanille verzichte ich denn hier
kommt jetzt abonnieren
eine prise salz das hebt immer den
geschmack eine prise tonkabohne sie
liebst du auch ganz ohne richten unsere
schokolade passt einfach perfekt so ein
bisschen verrührt werden schon
gesprochen kann der kakao dann genau
cacau 1
ja ich hab auch beachtet kann ja ich
auch warum das sagt man bei uns so war
es bei mir so kommt die sahne rein ja ja
jetzt die pfarrerin
das könnt ihr dann augen die mutter
schokoladenmasse wieder ab dann können
sie nämlich gleich mit den eiern vorfeld
des krebses könnt ihr auch die creme
verfeinern mit zitronen abrät passt
jetzt nicht ganz so gut aber orange nach
reparatur finde ich gut
ja ich mag es gern tonkabohne riecht ja
so bisserl nach mandeln und nach für
dich nicht mal wer mich recht klamm
durch riecht nach waldmeister
waldmeister gar nicht an stammt jeder
richter das müsse ja anderes super jan
wird klassen und jetzt kommt der
freundin in paris kommt nämlich deine
masse zu meiner als ihr seht man braucht
auch für dieses rezept eine
küchenmaschine solche die andere seite
wie du möchtest
[Musik]
die füllung ist bereits jetzt warten wir
nur noch auf den weg damit das schön
kalt wird und dann geht's wieder weiter
mit der tat form
[Musik]
der map guide der ist jetzt schön kalt
und jetzt wird er hier ausgerollt mit
ganz wenig mehr einfach etwa fünf
zentimeter größer als die tat form da
habe ich jetzt die tat vor mit hebe
boden richtig cool vor allem ist und
dann war ich schaffte es nie das dach
und jetzt bei mir wird immer eckig und
dann bevor mich denn irgendwie mit der
hand und ja es geht aber auch haupt
sommer kommt irgendwie zum ziel und ich
lese immer im untergrund ab also auf das
silikon matte ob ich schon die 30
zentimeter haare
ansonsten könnte aber auch einfach die
tat form auf den teig legen und dann
seht ihr schon ob es am rand reicht oder
nicht
trick war jetzt dann einmal kurz mit der
palette darunter falls doch was klebt
und ich hätte die tat vor mit gar nicht
denn der betrag hat ja schon genug wird
und der klebt auch wirklich gar nicht an
jetzt auf einmal überlegen wenn er am
rand reist ist gar nicht schlimm
das kann man nämlich sowie das
unternehmen schon reinsetzen
also darf man auch ein bisschen stückeln
und ich muss zugeben unser trägt er war
nicht nur stunde im kühlschrank wenn
eine stunde im kühlschrank gewesen wäre
würde er nicht reisen
das hatte den einfach nur eine
viertelstunde im gefrierschrank aber
eine stunde ist echt besser denn beim
backen behälter auch besser seine form
wieder geschummelt ja gibt seht es geht
aber es geht natürlich schöner und
besser wenn man ihnen lange genug fühlen
lässt kann man ihn auch ein gefrieren
ein franke doch welche teige kann man
nicht ein einfrieren alles was luftig
geschlagen wird es fertig ist wird
früher öl teig aber alles andere
mürbeteig kann so einfach im hefeteig
kannst du einen quark öl quark öl teig
werde ich glaube ich auch nie machen
aber da geht ja auch so schnell der
heinrich wegen dem backpulver manchmal
hätte ich dann angst dass das backpulver
einfach nicht mehr wirkt aber bei hefe
ist das gar kein problem
so wenn jetzt dann hat dann einfach oben
abstreifen und damit er jetzt beim
backen seine form behält wird er jetzt
für 15 minuten eingefroren
so wird dann richtig schön
[Musik]
jetzt wird die tat vorgebacken des blind
backen speicher mir also mit backpapier
und hülsenfrüchten wenn die taten
bisschen sich senkt drücke ich einfach
nach dem backen wieder fest und
vorgebacken wird damit der teig schon
durch ist und eben auch kosten
die tat steht jetzt so aus nach dem
backen und business gesunken das macht
aber gar nichts und wenn sie doch
irgendwo anderer stelle aufgegangen ist
einfach mit der müller für flach drücken
aber diese schon perfekt aus als ob
hitler man muss wirklich nichts machen
das jetzt nur kurz fünf minuten abkühlen
dann kommt erst die verlor ein schön
sitze aus jetzt ein für die tat ist
glaubt gladbacher überweisen wir dann
sehen
hinzu kam das ganze moderieren so man
kann nur eins sagen das hat dann so was
wollte ich sagen nix als ausstellung
füllung abschlecken und dann gibt es
hier diese schokoeier die haben so einen
zucker überzogen die gibt es eigentlich
immer zu ostern am tag geben wir jetzt
direkt und backen betreiben die hatten
nämlich dann im arm schnittstellen dabei
und die anderen die geben wir dann noch
nach dem backen obendrauf und der
fraunhofer truck so ein paar genau weil
die sinkende an seinem traktor nach
unten rein dann backen sinken ja und
jetzt habe ich schon den ofen ja genau
dem ofen runter gestellt auf 150 grad
ober unterhitze und da wird die zeit
gedanken macht darf ja auf den hafen
das ist schön
[Musik]
die tat ist jetzt gebacken und werden
sie abkühlen lassen
jetzt kommen noch die übrigen schoko er
drauf und die kann man einfach so bis
nach eindrücken in die braune masse
schön total schön so einfach in paraguay
haben wir hier aufgeschnitten dann stark
und der rav probieren und komma leeres
die kritische ist ganz einfach raus
durch die herbe boden auch ich dem
ganzen hier nämlich eine palette dann
kannst du nämlich auch
[Musik]
hier kommen sie aber kaum wir haben eine
braune tat fertig gebacken
ich glaube damals and er wird auch kein
problem aber marcel der kommt nicht ganz
fertig aber verschwiegen haben sogar
selber raus gesagt
doch was macht ihr die ihr hier und mag
schokoladen stapel
[Gelächter]
schokolade ist gut und es macht ja ich
glaube die männer die red ants hier auch
die erinnerung diesen rauen hier die
werden es lieben und ihr habt sehen
wirklich super super einfach wenn man
den teig gemacht kühl gestellt die
füllung macht alles rein sagt ratz fatz
rats und echt ein ganz ganz tolles
gericht ein tolles mitbringsel tolles
geschenk gab ja auch keine angst mehr
vertrags nein aber ich brauche die tat
form die mit anhängen und den hebel
boden bekommt nämlich auch im ganzen sie
daraus also falls ihr das rezept nach
machen wollt dann gibt es das auch
sallys - blog.de und was übrigens auch
richtig gut schmeckt stadt den bunten
eiern ihr könnt auch früchte rein machen
also den berner himbeeren weil ich mag
ja auch so diesem kontrast natürlich
auch und ich werde es mit ihm da machen
ja oder blaubeeren also wirklich gut hin
werdenberg glaube ich auch so mein
favorit oder kirschen im sommer dann
viel spaß beim nachmachen und bis zum
nächsten mal
und genial oder ich liebe hand ich bin
zusammen mit daran ja alles ist alles
rot rand jetzt ja jetzt kannst eine
konditorei bei uns mal ich finde dich
aus
[Musik]
oder christian rath gekommen
wir machen nämlich gleich unseren garten
fertig so christian stauch mittag
probiere ich hab ja vollkommen ohne
plastik produziert denkt es wäre das
erste mal stärke ach das ist kein gramm
plastik
das können wir jetzt mit dem kopf in die
erde setzen wird mit topf eingepflanzt
und das wozu dann dadurch nein das ist
ja genial das habe ich noch nie gesehen
baumschule hand du bist ja von dem ja
erzählt habe ja ja und was darf bei uns
eine tat probleme osterhofen ja wir
tauschen
dank toller sie haben direkt in die
küche und dann in den garten
guten appetit musste ich hoffe es
schmeckt dir
[Musik]
hey wie hasen warum hasen hat er in
paris genannt
ich denke ich nur kurz an deine zähne
angesagt da das werk in hannover und
szene